talk to me about the tie hookers the  only question is the one big question  yeah yeah yeah just if you go analy the  way then nothing matters yeah why are  you paying for box dude did you do  anything is it yeah yeah it's great  [ __ ] or no no I tried to get a  [ __ ]  because I've seen them and they're some  of them are gorgeous yeah like on a  level of like yeah even like a hot girls  of New York like that's right there with  any model I've seen yeah so I'm like I  should [ __ ] a [ __ ] unless I'm  homophobic the only reason not to do it  be a homophobic and I'm like I'm not  homophobic so yeah why wouldn't I  they're hot why would you not [ __ ] a hot  person but I'm like attract these people  it's only the idea that's there yeah so  I found one that was just gorgeous and I  was like let's go we got to the door and  then my my legs wasn't going I'm  homophobic  I don't think that makes you homophobic  I disagree  Thailand